bonsoir
[Musique]
mais tu vas être là toute la nuit
c'est presque tout
nous avons préparé une émission
spectaculaire avec les plus incroyables
les producteurs disent que les audiences
sont catastrophiques
regardez-vous je déteste
je suis le duc oui zelton
je vais te scanner
c'était déjà difficile d'être petit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'arrive comme ça
je crois que je vais plutôt approcher la
table ça va me faire transpirer un peu
avant le concert mais tout va bien
la famille que tu as de riche les amis
que tu choisis il devient des membres de
ta famille et avec toutes ces choses là
tu te sentiras jamais rabaissé-ternois
j'ai vu le seul endroit où il y a pas de
laine sur un mouton
[Musique]